bonjour merci d'être avec mon direct sur
rtl france à leur première question que
pensez vous de cette tête est ce
légitime selon vous que enzo soient
sanctionnées
des sceaux a
utilisé son logiciel l'a vendu un
certain nombre de pays avec l'accord et
l'autorisation de du pays israël qui est
celui qui autorise ce type de diffusion
internationale de ces deux dispositifs
oui bien sûr je pense que les des sceaux
n'a absolument rien à faire dans ce vin
mais c'est un à un des maillons un des
maillons simplement de la chaîne rien à
faire dans cette danse est surveillé en
sa terre étatique bien évidemment on
sait très bien comment ça fonctionne
aujourd'hui et les sauts par l'effet des
sanctions américaines déjà et peut-être
européenne dans quelques quelques
semaines et déjà au bord du dépôt de
bilan
aujourd'hui les pays qui ont été
espionnées ont fait nécessaires de
manière suffisamment mettre de poids
auprès de gouvernement israélien pour
que cette firme dessau soit mise un
petit peu au banc delà de la communauté
maintenant il nous reste plein d'autres
et on a compté jusqu'à 2 127 entreprises
qui seraient titulaires de de la
technologie pour pouvoir opérer ce type
de ce type d' espionnage en israël il y
en a une vingtaine encore encore
opérationnel donc bon c'est très très
bien d'interdire l'interdire cesser ces
logiciels et de mettre un petit peu la
la la la honte sur les opérations un
certain nombre d'entreprises mais il
faut peut-être agir de manière beaucoup
plus globale pour interdire complètement
cesser ces dispositifs ça veut dire quoi
qu'on doit s'inquiéter et qu'on doit
craindre l'arrivée d'autres
cyber-menaces à l'image de pegasus bien
évidemment bien évidemment parce que
c'est pas parce que pegasus va être mis
entre parenthèses pendant un certain
temps que pour autant les l'espionnage
va s'arrêter ça serait faire preuve de
beaucoup de de candeur dont on sait
l'espionnage fonctionne depuis la nuit
des temps alors par différents moyens
aujourd'hui le la cyber surveillance est
devenu quelque chose de
extrêmement extrêmement pratique et
utile et pratiquement indécelable il a
fallu vraiment des investigations
extrêmement poussé là par ce consortium
pour déceler les failles les failles
très très réduit du logiciel pegasus
donc d'autres logiciels existent
d'autres logiciels aujourd'hui
fonctionnent des pays en espionne
d'autres c'est on va dire la règle un
peu la règle du jeu international et
donc il est totalement illusoire à mon
sens de penser que ça va s'arrêter
simplement parce que on va mettre ou à
mettre des coups de bâton sur sûre et
des sceaux alors les états unis ont
donné sept combattons en tout cas le
département d'état américain en place et
nassau sur sa liste noire alors pourquoi
les états unis epa l'union européenne
est ce qu'il ya des intérêts peut-être
qui nous échappe
il y à la cybersurveillance d'un côté et
puis il ya les les intérêts de des pays
qui sont qui sont concernés concernant
la france par exemple on est dans un
triangle avec le maroc qui nous a
beaucoup espionner manifestement et puis
israël qui est donc l'autre le le pays
qui donne l'autorisation de vendre
les les logiciels
manifestement il ya eu certain nombre
d'accords qu'ils sont intervenus puisque
de la liste qui était au départ
extrêmement pourvu de pays qui pouvait
être destinataire de ce type de
dispositif donc il y avait à peu près de
100 pays aujourd'hui je crois qu'il ne
reste plus que 37 donc la france
pourrait aujourd'hui totalement acquérir
pegasus ou d'autres pays de l'union
européenne certains l'ont déjà fait bien
évidemment on pense notamment à
l'allemagne
donc oui il ya des intérêts des intérêts
bilatéraux trilatéraux régionaux on va
pas se fâcher avec untel et untel bon on
a été pris dans le la main dans le sac
mais bon derrière il va y avoir il va y
avoir des négociations
le ski est très très compliqué dans ce
type de cyber surveillance et de et de
sanction c'est y en a pas de sanction
justement le défaut de sanction par
rapport aux pays qui autorise ce type de
ce dispositif et qui avait 10 la mise en
place d'une cyber surveillance et les a
manifestement il faudrait qu'il soit
soit sanctionné il ne se passe rien donc
on a toujours ses petits marchés entre
amis et relations diplomatiques derrière
qui vont faire qu'on va continuer ainsi
avant la vie très très longtemps ce ce
type de surveillance et avec le la
progression de la technologie donc ça
serait beaucoup plus facile et il n'y a
pas de précédent au niveau du droit
européen
non à ma connaissance aucun pays n'a été
sanctionné de quelques manières que ce
soit parce qu'il a suivie la ilaha illa
surveiller son son voisin lorsque
l'allemagne l'a fait par rapport à la
france ce n'est pas eu a priori
connaissance une vie eu des des
représailles ou des sanctions qui était
faite contre soit 2 3 1
d'autres vins donc non et tout ça tout
ça se fait de manière au su et au vu et
au su de tout le monde ou presque on
sait que ça se passe le tout ce n'est
pas ce faire se faire attraper bon quand
on est on est un petit peu démunis et
lorsque l'onu demande un moratoire sur
ces sur ces dispositifs comme il l'a
fait au mois de juillet c'est tout à
fait tout à fait intéressant maintenant
derrière il faudrait vraiment qu'il soit
plus ça puisse être suivie d'une d'une
palette de sanctions qui permette
vraiment des dissuasif par rapport à
l'utilisation de ces dossiers ce
logiciel de surveillance à thierry voilà
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
l'appel vous êtes avocat au barreau de
paris et spécialiste du numérique
mercier